就是说你营造一个啥样的世界，你在前十分钟要干出来。
很多人觉得这是句废话。
所以就给忽略了，这不是废话啊，一定要把你世界观构建出来。
比如说。
假设你拍一个呃这个这个很多年轻人喜欢写的高中生活。
对吧。
你你你你。
你要营造一个什么样的世世界观？就虽然同样是高中校园啊，世界观也可以不一样的。
就比如说我想赢到高三那种。
你死我活的拼杀。
这个这一种生活啊，就是我上去你就下来了，咱学校就考俩北大，对吧？我上你就下就我想营造那种世界观，那是一种世界观。或者你想营造那种啊十七八岁天真烂漫美美好的那个懵懂的小爱情，那也是一种对高中生活的理解。
就说这个这个。
这里的世界观你要你要搞出来了。
对吧你像如果是一场我们说商业大战的那种。
那种那个那个。
商战类型的那种故事。
创业类型的故事。那在这里这个世界观比如说金钱至上，有钱就是说了算。
对吧有钱就是说了算。
金钱至上，那你就要前十局十分钟把这个十几万搞出来啊。
搞出来呀。
对吧。
所以说这个铺垫啊前十分钟。
做这个事儿的人物，所有的人物的出场，所有人物的出场。思老师说的啊，所有人物的出场。然后呢。
主题。
主题第5分钟把主题点掉。
然后。
世界观这是一个啥样的世界？
说这是个弱肉强食的世界，对吧？这是一个民不聊生的世界。
这是一个万家灯火欣欣向荣的时界。
这是一个战火连天的事件。
前十分钟把这个世界观给我勾勒出来。
勾勒出来。
然后我说点主题在第5分钟点。
思思老师说了，司老师说点主题要用嘴点。
要用台词点思老师说的啊，思老师说在第5分钟的时候，需要有人用嘴巴用台词把主题给我点出来。他的其实啥意思啊？就是要明确的点出来。
明确的点出主题来。
可以不是主角的嘴。
也可以是一个很次要的角色的嘴。但是要有人说出来。
人家说有钱就可以为所欲为吗？然后这个人哎就是这样这言词叫什么？哎，就是可以为所欲为，对吧？
哎，你说对了，有钱就是可以为所欲为。
把主题点出来。
用嘴一点啊。
然后12分钟推动，其实就是我们经常说的激励时件。
就激励事件开始集。
开始击在12分钟开始击。因为斯奈德先生认为是比较重视激励事件的，他认为12分钟先击一下，然后12到15分钟主角产生了争执，就说我被击了。
对吧。
常见的激利事件来。
呃，那个比如说我是哈利波特，他们虐待我。
我这个养父母虐待我呀。
他们打我欺负我不给我饭吃。
他们不可能第一12分钟第一次虐待你，但你不可能一虐待你，你就。
你就跑吧，你就离家出走吧，你这个主角还是要有点那个那个。
不能做事儿这么唐突。所以12分钟的时候先击你一下，激完了你以后呢，你是产生争执的。比如说。
比如说你的养父母虐待你。
虐待了你第一次之后，你你的第一反应是，那我好好表现呀。
对吧我考了1个100分，或者是我出去呃捡炮弹儿挣了20块钱，我回来交给我养母。
这就是争执，就是我想用。
其实就是我说的一思。
人家对你不好，那你好好表现呗，依次动作这是正常的动作。结果发现他们又揍我，他们还说这20块钱是不是你投的？我那天丢了20呀，你那个不要脸的杨母说你明明捡破烂，辛辛苦苦挣的20，对吧？他说是他那天丢了20，你他他丢了那那20是一张整的。
我捡破盖收的这是他妈一把零钱呀。
他就这么冤枉你。
对吧你这不就是自己该在自己争执吗？然后想想妈这个臭娘们，想想手里还有老鼠药。
下毒对吧？所以就是说12分钟时候开始开始激励，你可以视为激励事件的起点。
然后12到15是整个反复集忆，就说你这个养母啊揍你好几回，你才弄死他。
而且当中你是有争执的，你是先尝试跟他好好沟通，尝试对他好一点。
好吧。
这就是斯耐德先生对起的25分钟的。
呃，更详细的拆解。
更详细的拆解争执。
是12到25啊，推动的12明白了吧？
好，我们往下说。
成这个阶段啊是30分钟。
在这里。
他现在25分钟这个位置做一个叫衔接点。
25分钟做一个衔接点。
然后。
B故事是30分钟，B故事网上流行英语啊AB故事待会给大家详细说一下啊，以后听到别人问点品在你面前AB故事B故事A故事B故事咱也不怕啊，咱也不怕，别被他们唬住好吗？不要整AB就就就就觉得唬人了，我给你们讲一讲是怎么。
事啊。
30分钟的时候，B务室。
然后。
我们说你看啊30到50。
30到50，它叫。
游戏。
30到50。
怎么把350给框起来。
是游戏。
我们说到这儿是55嘛，对吧？
然后。
55。
这里做一个终点。
55这里做一个终点。
这是他对第二阶段的一个细分。
啥意思呢？
啥意思呢？这一段其实很好理解，而且这一段是泄力的一段。
我们说前20文中是蓄力。
你信息量也大。
情节相对也有力度，你的后妈老打你呀。
下下死手。
所以这里其实是蓄力。
挺狠的。
第二阶段呢乘这个阶段起承转和乘这个阶段其实是一个泄力的一个一个阶段。我们先来说它细分的这几点，25分钟开始衔接点。
衔接点它为什么叫衔接点啊？其实是其实是一个变化点。
变化点。
就说你看啊。
在25分钟这里啊，你经过这个推动加争执，强烈的刺激。
激励实件吗？必然对你带来强烈的刺激啊。
自激完了以后，你终于决定。
开启你的过激行为了。
正常行为你试过了。
你不干或开始你的过激行为了。
开始过激行为，这个事儿呢一般来说是比较大。
或者是说是比较重的。
甚至有时候是铤而走险的。
对不对？
那么在这里是需要有一点。
仪式感。
就假设你是离家出走。
那么在这里。
必然会有一场。
披星戴月的戏。
就是夜黑风高，披星戴月，就是那种。
雄赳赳气昂昂的心。
你可以想象成就是如果是一个古代的片子，那这在25分钟必然有一场。
我们的男主角骑着马。
走进夕阳。
的那么一个镜头。
放着悲怆的音乐。
会在25分钟出现，啥意思啊？就是得有点仪式感，让你的观众。
明确的知道我的角色上路了。
他上路了。
就是他做出决定了，被刺激了以后，做出决定了，在这里要搞一点仪式感。
就是在25分钟这个衔金点在这里。
所以这个斯迈德是说他这里叫一个什么新生活新开端。
啊，就是这个意思，他在这里开启一段新的旅程。
这么想，他不一定是上路啊，我们不能总理解为公路偏啊，就走出去了。很有可能就是开始筹划干毒死他干嘛也可以嘛，他不一定要离家出走啊。
然后B故事在30分钟做，我就说啥叫AB故事。
啥叫B故事？那那就得先说成啥叫A故事。
在在在在在这个教学中，他们经常提AB故事。
A故事就是你这个故事呃，你这个电影表面的那个故事。
以小蝌蚪找妈妈为例。
A故事就是小蝌蚪。
这一路上去寻找自己的妈妈，这整个旅程叫A故事。
我们说小蝌蚪找妈妈。
是是呃。
想找的妈妈是动作，他的欲望其实是。
事是是证明自己的身世啊，找自己的身世呃想知道自己是谁。我说我在那一节课中我说过，他最后可以没有找到妈妈，但是呢他证明了自己的价值，完成了自己的蜕变，成为了一个有担当的小蝌蚪，拯救甚至帮助了朋友，拯救了危机，啥啥的。
就是他完成了自己的蜕变。然后在这个成长和这个自我价值的体现面前，我的妈妈具体是谁？我究竟是个蛤蟆还是个青蛙，已经不重要。
这个就是B50。
B故事A故事是表面故事的进展，B故事是内人物内心的旅程。你可以这么去理解。
或者是说叫人物湖光啊，人物弧线吧。
就是闭故式，就是他人他内在的成长，他内在这个这个旅程，你可以理解为闭故事。所以在30分钟这里是闭故式的起点。
就B故是开始开开启了，因为他前面没有成长啊，明白这个意思吗？他前面其实没有成长，他在他在受迫害呀。
他在遭罪呢。
对吧。
我不是说过吗？我说那个那个你要你的人物可怜可信可爱吗？
你不就是在这儿做吗？
前25分钟，我跟你说，你都很多同学说老师我这没有事儿，我没有事儿可写，我这哪那么填这个空，可怜可亲可爱不够，你忙活了。
你在这我跟你说，你都忙不过来。
你有可能都写超了，25分钟你都拦不住你，你就得做减法。
对吧。
你你在这里你你的主角。
这这这有的事儿可以做了。
然后在30分钟的时候。
你的庇护是要开始起点的。
就是他比如说他假设是小蝌蚪找妈妈这个故事，那在30分钟这里，他就要开始有一些自我价值认知的觉醒了。
就他开始感觉到哎。
诶。
我好像有价值。
刚刚开始啊，还没有证明自己很大的价值，但是感觉到自己有价值了。在30分钟这里，所以他专门在这里点一下B故事的起点。因为他觉得这个很重要。但其实在我们讲时序列的时候，我们也没有把人物弧光，人物弧线放弃。
懂这个意思吗？所以并不是说他这个更细，它练成15个就牛逼了吗？哎，不对不对不对，咱们这节课尊重斯莱德节待器啊，我又给忘了，这里是闭故式的起点。
好吧，大家理解一下，然后游戏很多人不理解啊，啥叫游戏？
30到50分钟，顺便说一句啊，B故式的起点这里啊往往也是。
感情线的起点。
感情线的起点就说他如果你这个主角是一个人开始是一个人登场上路，那么他的爱情发生在。
必不是起待这里。
感情这，因为一般啊你的。
你如果把你的爱情做进故事里了啊，就是你这个故事里面你有涉计爱情的话，那么你这个人物成长是伴随着爱情的。
是伴随着爱情的，或或者伴随着感情的，伴随着兄弟情也可以。就是说因为你的人物成长也是需要个轨迹，需要个依托嘛。你是你如果是有有感情线的话，那在比谷时就要萌发了。要么是你这个爱情对象。
登场。
要不是你俩啊呃擦擦擦出点花，你正好也上路了嘛。
正好你们离家出走也上路了嘛？25分钟的时候离家出走了，到30分钟差不多。哎，第一次在外面过夜了嘛，在一个那个呃那个路边草房子里，对吧？就天降大雨，点上了一团篝火，然后说哥哥温了，然后脱了衣服给你烤一烤，就在30分钟这里烤，明白吗？
在30分钟内烤个火。
冷呀怎么办？那只能抱着取暖了。
好吧，这是呃这个B股市这个这个B股市起点，这里呃也是感情线的一个大点。
啊，这里多提一句啊。
游戏时间游戏时间是啥呢？
而且你看啊30到50。
20分钟的游戏时间呀。
25分钟的游戏时间怎么这么长呢？
这里是干啥？是泄力的。
我说过，你看啊，咱们前前面这个企啊其实是很很很沉重的对吧？然后呢，到了25分钟到30这一段呢，其实事儿也挺多的，你又要做仪式感，又要开启闭故式感情线，就你一直在给观众不停的在传达信息。
观众挺累的。
所以就是用20分钟的时间让观众休息。
用观众休息如何才能让观众休息啊？不是说让观众给观众看一些没用的东西，就让观众休息了。什么叫让观众休息？
我以前也讲过，所以说思老师这套东西我以前其实都讲过，什么叫让观众休息？
我在。
八要素的时候就是讲过。
就是什么啊？就是满足观众的预期。
符合观众的预期。
这就是要让观众去休息。
让观众休息。
就是所谓的游戏时间。
我们就以离家出走为例。
假设啊你跟别人说，哎，我给你讲一个。
有一个少少年，有个小伙嗯，12岁一个小男孩，后他他这个后妈对他不好，然后呢他。
离家出走了，他准备到远方。
找他亲吧。
比如说他发现一个线索。
大概知道他亲妈在哪。
菊次郎的夏天。
当然沮丧的夏天人没有后妈虐待。
我就说那他离家出走。
到一个远方的城市，从从一个小山村到一个远方城市。
来，我跟你说，我给你讲一个这样的故事，你脑子里面出现的第一个画面是什么？
你脑子里面出现的第一个画面是一个绿色的大山，一个蜿蜒的小路，然后一个孤独的小男孩，有小背影在那个小路上，你知道吗？甚至还拎着一个小包。
或许还带着一个草帽。
然后呢，就这么一个孤独的小背影，穿着一个白T恤，一个小短，一个蓝色的短裤。
拎着一个小包，脑子里想的就是这个。
对吧我说1个12岁的少年被人虐待，在一个小山村里，他要到远方的城市里去找他亲妈，独自上路。你脑子里有没有想到就是这个小男孩呃，在一个大山的一个蜿蜒的路上，一个背影，风餐露宿，对吧？
然后呢，赤路边的。
摘的玉米。
摘着苹果。
你脑子里面会想到这些第一时间想到的这些东西。
就是你对这个故事的期待。
就在这。
所以它叫游戏，哎，确实像游戏啊，摘苹果抓蚂蚱。
躲雨到呃因为离开家了，不能在浴室洗澡了，要在河里洗澡。
路边的河里瀑布，洗个澡，啊一下跳进去。
这不就是游戏吗？
游戏时间。
但是说游戏时间不太好理解，你就理解成什么啊，满足观众对这个戏这个题材的想象。
对这个题材的想象。
20度。
如果是一个那种片啊，还有经常不一定是做游戏啊。如果是一个我们说哎那个有一个。
嗯。
星仔要我们给你讲一个故事，一个送外卖的星仔，因为因为爱情要跟世界空手道冠军断水流大师兄打一架。
你脑子里想象的游戏时间一定是他在训练。
就说你这外卖仔怎么打打钻石流亚石油，因为他同他用中国股权法，你想的就是训练，所以30到50就是训练。
就是他在先练腿，再练手，再练吊在吊车上，然后再练无敌风火轮。
就是他的训练过程。
也相当于是游戏这过程。
所以在这一段呢，在这个过程。
一般还会配一些就节奏会快起来轻快，因为它信息量太少。
就是他对大剧情其实是没有帮助的，它是让观众休息的。
往往就是它出镜头会比较快，甚至配一些比较欢快的。
呃，背景音乐。
就知道一下啊，这就是所谓的。
游戏时间啊，对，这个斯戴德先生的教材里面啊，对这个游戏时间还有一个有趣的描述，就是他说就是拍你电影海报上的画面。
说的挺准的。
说的挺准的，你知道吗？就是你海你这个电影海报的画面不就是观众对你这个电影的想象。
那个小孤嘟的小男孩在这个小山路上拎了一个小包，是不是背这个小双肩包？
孤独的小男孩，一个小背影。
你拍1个12岁小男孩离家出走的电影，因为后妈打他离家出走的电影，你的海报一定是这个。
一定是他一个弱小的小背影，然后背这个小包在那个一条蜿蜒的小路上。
跋设那条路一直通往天边，跟跟蓝天相连，对不对？你一定要找一条这样的路。
还一个小男孩的背影。
他如果有伙伴，那就拉着一个那个他妹妹的小手更可怜，对不对？所以赛德先生说游戏时间就是拍你的海报。
来，围着你的海报拍也是对的。
对的。
海报。
这个说法也很有趣啊。然后我们说55分钟的时候，你看253055分钟终点。
重点。
我们在实序列中，我们管终点叫转折点。
转折点。
确实呀在这里要转折了呀，你他妈爽到现在了。
那还爽吗？
闯到头了。
爽到头了。
所以5分55分钟这个打点，斯耐德先生管他叫终点，然后他对这个终点的定义。
他的原话叫伪胜利。
伪胜率。
其实也就是虚假的成功。
你可以这么理解。
虚假的一个小甜头，阶段性的一个小成果，但是是假的。
就是你。
如愿以偿一件事情。
假的胜利，你开始追求一个虚假的一个东西，先得到。
然后在菊次郎的夏天里面。
在这里基本上他就是到了目的地了。
他不是要找他妈吗？
到城里去找他亲妈妈。
但是他的亲妈并不是。
他听说的那样。
呃，在。
城里打工挣钱，为了养活他。
他起码早就不咬他。
早就又生小孩了。
也是个小男孩。
因为他们起妈已经不要他了，他起妈知道他在农村也从来不去看他，他起妈也不苦，过着很好的生活，住打别墅。
所以。
这里就是一个虚假的胜利，就是在55分钟里找到他起码了。
找到他去。
虚假的。
这利。
当然这是一种处理方式啊，还有常见的处理处理方式，就是在这里嗯获得了一个。
短暂的甜头，但是辜负了朋友。
就你我两个人上路的，在这里基本上跟你朋友闹掰了。
因为选择闹掰了。
比如说面对一个选择，你认为。
哎，这里嗯。
这于这个。
走这条路更好。
对吧走这条路有几个人愿意帮我？
他们这个这个这个可以帮我快速的实现后面的目标。然后但是你的朋友不同意，你的朋友说那几个人不像好人，你不要跟他们走。
但是你不听。
然后呢。
就跟那几个人走了，你在这里辜负了朋友。
但这这里是一个虚假的胜利，为什么？是因为你的选择战胜了你朋友的选择，你把它说服了嘛。
所以你们选择了。
这条路径你认为对的路径。
这也是一种虚假的胜利。终点就你跟你朋友打打闹闹很欢乐。到这里的时候，有一个虚假的胜利，就是你你。
你做出的选择是你认为是对的，然后听了你的。
但是埋下了原罪，埋下了伏笔，而且你伤害了朋友，这也是一种处理方式，但这这也不绝对啊。我就说在终点这里啊一般会遇到什么事儿。
所以在这里啊就是一个假胜利，但是要埋伏笔埋伏笔。
这就是到55站。
然后接下来又是1个30分钟，都有啥呢？我们说。
这里是55，所以这到这里是85啊，我们说。
55到75。
叫坏蛋逼进呢。
坏蛋逼竟他他说是55到75。
55到75。
然后一无所有，那75这里就一无所有了。
75这里就一无所有了。
坏蛋过来75分钟把你干到。
干趴下。
然后75到85就是到85，这儿75。
到85。
这里就是我们经常说的。
灵魂黑夜。
就是经常会提到的灵魂黑夜，就是在这10分钟。
所以在这个转这里啊，为什么叫转啊？就是情况急转直下，这里是情况是昂扬向上的，转这里情情况急转直下。
首先55到275有个长达20分钟的坏蛋逼近，在这里可以是有战斗的啊，不不一定非得是偷偷逼近，可以是有摩擦，可以开始逃，对吧？气氛开始紧张起来了，一一次、两次、二次三次的来来呃给你。
我们说坏蛋其实就是给你阻力嘛。
呃，给你搞阻力，我们说阻力也也环境也跟你做对，对手也跟你做对，你自己也跟你做对，对吧？就是75到255到75是一个猪肚子。
所谓的坏蛋逼近，在这里这个呃坏蛋逼近的这个过程，你不要只孤立的看这20分钟。
你前面要买福利的。
你前面要买伏笔的坏蛋有可能在前十分钟出过场。
或者是在你这个增执和推动的这个过程中。
对吧你你也做过伏笔，或者是在游戏时间里，你过于猖狂，也打过伏笔，对吧？
就是是你前面是要做伏笔的，不要孤立的写。
然后在75分钟的时候。
把你打趴下。
这里可以受个重创。
受伤。
甚至我说的，你你让男儿就可以在这儿就死了，也可以，就是在这个点在这个点。
那个斯戴德先生呃的原话说，一无所有，这里要展现死亡气息。
就是这个意思，他说的就是这个意思。因为在传统的影片里面啊，在古老的故事里面，这里确实就是死人。
就是。
真的死。
但是因为在现代片里面，现代故事里面，你不可能每个片子都死人了呀，做不到的呀。所以在那个呃那套教材里面，它有个概念叫高度叫概念化的死亡。
叫概念化的死亡，这不是真死，但是跟死亡同等的。
功效。
在这里就要用到了。
用到概念化的死亡。
弥漫着死亡气息的世界，对吧？
拿二死。
死啦或者是你的重叛轻的一啊。
那不也跟死了一样啊，你的所有朋友都不搭理。
或者是对你产生了。
深深的误解。
对吧。
或者是你你做点事事情，让你你这这里让你前途尽毁。
反正是弥漫死亡气息的重大事件。哎，你就这么理解吧，就在这可以打到底了。
75分钟给你打到底了。
要多惨有多惨。
越踩越好，给你打道理。
好吧，755到75是一直在打你吗？
75打到底，然后75到85就是所谓的灵魂黑夜。
也就是你的蜕变过程。
这十0分钟你你已经被打到黑夜了，你也想过放弃，甚至实际意义上都已经实施放弃了。你在这里就是。
为什么有1分钟的篇幅啊？
就是全方位的展示你的痛苦。
就全方位的展示你的痛苦。
你的痛苦的过程，你的舔舐伤口的过程。
你的蜕变和重生的过程都是在这里十分钟。
这里其实是外在的惨。
在75分钟达到外在的，这里用10分钟展现你精神世界的。
痛苦。
灵魂的黑夜。
15分钟。
所以他这两段是相当于猪肚子。
各30分钟以上一下。
他是这么大的。
然后最后25分钟，85这里他又搞了一个所谓的。
衔接点。
在85啊。
前节点。
85这里情节点。
然后85到110。
就是。
那个我们所谓的。
结局其实就是高潮啊其实就是高潮啊结局就是高潮嘛，是85到110。
然后最后110这里。
又是一个。
画面。
就最后25分钟，他又分了这三个部分。
85这个衔接点是什么呢？就是柳暗花明。
或者是叫解决方案的诞生。你突然发现我还有一招。
我还有一招。
还有孤注一掷的一招。
解决方案。
或者是最难的那条路，我之前不想走的那条路。
简单说就是跟他们拼了。
就是你前面各种方案都用了，不行，最后的衔接点就解决方案就是。
下毒也没有用。
呃，举报他嫖娼也没有用。
这个呃给他呃那个吃的饭里面下泻药也没有用，对吧？然后雇人去偷袭他也没有用。
最后这个断血流大师兄只能我自己去面对了，就上擂一台，其实就孤注一掷。最后的那个。
解决方案。
斯戴德先生说，这里是解决方案的诞生，但其实呢。
很难在一个戏里面在8就是说前85分钟都没有这么好的办法，就在85分钟的时候，突然哎哎哗。
灵机一动出来一个这么好的解决方案。那你前面这个男二死的也太冤了。
是不是啊以前那这以前的经历这么黑暗的时刻，在85分钟突然灵激动，哎，我有主意了。
是比较难的。
所以嗯解决方案的诞生，你这么理解也行，但是我更愿意把它理解为。
直面困难。
或者是说要孤注一掷。
就是说这个解决方案其实原本也有，只不过你不想走，就是拼了呗。
就是跟坏蛋拼了呗。
对吧就是偏冷。
也可以是救命稻草。
就是呃出现转机也有这样的戏，确实有啊，就在这里出现转机，出现最后一根救命稻草。
85分钟，然后85到110啊。
我们说这里你看。
85到110。
对吧。
就是整个25分钟。
85到110嘛。
整个最后25分钟也是最长的一段，就是高潮。我们说一个戏的高潮最长，这很正常。
因为你整个戏最过瘾的地方就在这儿了，25分钟。如果是一个孤胆英雄的戏，那这25分钟就是冲到最后的那个场景，最后的那个废旧的厂房，仓库里面最后的那一场大战呀。
嗯大概25分钟不过分呀。
对吧就是最后的那场大战。
带为那个特效，带慢动作，带为各种。
那你25分钟确实可以在这折腾一下，这往往是一个电影最花钱的地方，就在这25分钟时就是烧钱。
啊，你所有的看家的绝活都都搞出来。
这里就推向最高潮，最后那几下。
推向最高潮。
这个很容易理解啊。
你写到这的时候，你很容易理解你要干什么？
嗯，我给大家看的那个那个。
定制半郎啊，那最这里不就是最后的婚礼吗？最后结婚那场戏嘛？对吧？我们说那个花生花生酱英雄花生酱猎鹰，我给大家也放过，这里不就是最后那场比赛吗？
他成为了那个智障的小男孩成为了。
成为了那个那个那个那个摔跤手，成为了博呃呃这个拳击手。
打的那场，最后的那场比赛嘛，惊心动魄的那比赛嘛，是源人、丹泽尔、华盛顿最后在那个。
他工作的家具厂。
跟俄罗斯黑帮等等场。
决斗嘛。
他用钉枪，对对方用机关枪，他用射钉枪在家具城嘛，最后那场决斗嘛。
这里很容易理解啊，这25分钟。
然后再就剩最后一个。
110分钟的时候，又一个画面。
我们说这里就叫中场画面。
开始的时候是一个开场画面。就说斯耐德先生说这个中场画面。
真。
开场画面要做呼应。
确实啊有很多电影是这么做的，就开场。
画画面。
我们说开场画面。
干嘛呢？来？
确定一个片子的。
气质类型。
中场这个画面要跟。
开场的那个画面似而不同。
所以很规矩的做法就是。
再回到这个画面。
但是有一些关键的因素。
关键元素已经变了。
就说似而不同。
你能理解吗？
就小蝌蚪找妈妈开始是一个安静的小池塘，小蝌蚪被人欺负。
结束的画面可以还是这个安静的小池小池塘。
但是小蝌头已经不是那个小蝌头。
或者是四而不同，小蝌蚪相同。就是说开场画面，小蝌蚪在这个小池塘的一角被人欺负。
然后呢，结束的画面还是小蝌蚪还是在这个角，小蝌蚪在帮助别人。
就说它是有相同的元素在，也有不同的元素。
形成一个呼应。
这就是。
同学们反复问的。
揭拍表。
其实跟我们的实序列。
是差不多的。
没有没有。
没有。
没有细化到。
就稍微往下细了一下。
我希望对大家。
想出事儿啊。
有所帮助。
好吧。
有什么不懂，有什么不懂的，或者还有什么疑问，我们继续在群里说。我今天就是给大家查漏补缺一下，说一下这个所谓的节拍表。
好吗？
大哥。